[Musique]
bonjour C'est Guérini bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre premier invité
politique de la saison merci d'être avec
nous c'était ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique en étant ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour Fabrice vesser Redon bonjour
Oriane bonjour
Fabrice du groupe pebra tous les
journaux régionaux de l'Est de la France
on va évidemment commencer par
l'actualité au Maroc Stanislas Guerini
plus de 2000 morts dans ce séisme qui a
touché le Maroc vendredi soir que va
faire que peut faire aujourd'hui la
France pour aider le Maroc alors qu'on a
appris hier soir que la France ne
figurait pas sur la liste des pays dont
le Maroc se licite LED d'abord une
pensée pour tous nos amis marocains pour
nos concitoyens aussi français puisque
les quatre Français ont perdu la vie à
cette heure d'autres sont blessés c'est
un drame d'une ampleur
tragique évidemment et évidemment la
France est aux côtés se tient prêt aux
côtés du Maroc dans les premières
minutes les autorités françaises loin
indiquées nous sommes prêts à venir
aider beaucoup de force d'ailleurs de la
société civile viennent aider des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires l'ont fait
immédiatement des associations des
entreprises les autorités françaises
sont prêtes le Maroc est souverain et
c'est bien normal ainsi mais il faut
avant tout penser à une catastrophe
humanitaire et donc être prêt à venir en
aide ne sollicite pas l'aide de la
France la crise est si profonde entre
les deux pays je pense que d'abord c'est
pas le temps pour ça vraiment très
sincèrement c'est une catastrophe
humanitaire la première priorité c'est
que le Maroc puisse organiser les
secours puisse venir prêter main-forte
au disparu aussi parce qu'il y a dans
les moments où on est en train de parler
encore ces opérations là qui sont en
train de se passer je crois que c'est
pas un moment pour parler diplomatie
internationale c'est un moment
simplement pour être prêt à venir aider
pour en tirer ensuite des conséquences
vous savez
le peuple français extrêmement proche du
peuple marocain hier j'étais des forums
des associations on voit bien à quel
point beaucoup de nos concitoyens sont
parfois franco-marocain et avaient le
cœur au Maroc je crois que c'est le cas
pour tous les responsables politiques
donc pour la France que le Maroc refait
son aide le Maroc a décidé de d'ouvrir à
quatre pays pour l'instant je suis assez
convaincu qui continueront à ouvrir à
d'autres pays pour venir aider tout
simplement
mes affaires étrangères Catherine colère
à l'occasion de s'exprimer ce matin en
tout cas il y a pas d'ambiguïté la
France à la minute ou le Maroc le
souhaitera sera assez pour pouvoir venir
aider un peu plus positif après tous les
moyens et au fond la science française
pour savoir venir porter secours il y a
des moyens qui sont extrêmement
importants qui sont toujours mobilisés
au moment où nos voisins en ont besoin
ça sera le cas à nouveau mais je pense
que la ministre des Affaires étrangères
donnera plus de précisions sur ces
moyens là on va parler d'un autre sujet
c'est l'inflation qui touche évidemment
les Français aux porte-monnaie est-ce
qu'il faut une aide pour les carburants
comme le demande hier françois Bayrou
dans les colonnes du Parisien vous savez
au fond on a fait le quoi qu'il en coûte
de l'inflation ces derniers mois ça
portait des résultats la France a eu un
niveau d'inflation bien moindre que
l'ensemble de ses voisins européens mais
il faut maintenant aussi retrouver le
chemin de finances publiques qui sont
assainies puisque sinon on va tous payer
ça demain et ce sont nos enfants qui
paieront des décisions d'aujourd'hui
donc il faut de la responsabilité il
faut faire ce que fait Bruno Lemaire je
fais le gouvernement que je participe
c'est-à-dire mettre la pression
de l'État depuis le début nous avons à
chaque fois mis la pression j'entends
parfois des responsables politiques qui
disent qu'on vient faire la manche mais
tout ça c'est parfaitement ridicule nous
avons obtenu des résultats mais la
pression sur les acteurs industriels
pour réussir à parvenir à maîtriser
petit à petit l'inflation il faut faire
la même chose sur les carburants c'est
ce que nous faisons mais vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec François beroux
c'est aux entreprises de faire un effroi
dans le moment dans lequel nous sommes
c'est aux entreprises et c'est cet
effort-là que nous leur demandons avec
déjà des résultats total annoncer un
effort il faut qu'il puisse le
poursuivre je crois que c'est ça la
bonne voie pour maîtriser l'inflation
aujourd'hui Fabrice sur cette question
qui est annoncée pour octobre est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre à une nouvelle
hausse de salaire notamment sur les bas
salaires dans la fonction publique
je vais y venir mais la question qui est
traitée par cette conférence sociale
c'est l'ensemble des branches qui sont
au-dessous des minima sociaux et on sait
qu'un certain nombre de branches ne joue
pas suffisamment de jeu et donc je
trouve extrêmement positif qu'on puisse
là aussi demander aux acteurs de prendre
leur responsabilités c'était un résultat
immédiati de la réunion du président de
la République de la première ministre
avec l'ensemble des forces politiques
c'était un point de consensus donc il y
aura cette conférence sur les employeurs
qui ne jouent pas le jeu ça n'est pas le
cas de la fonction publique vous le
savez on a pris avant l'été des
décisions importantes pour relever les
cernes dans la fonction publique
évidemment aujourd'hui par un agent
public c'est bien normal mais rémunéré
en dessous du SMIC mais vous avez raison
la question de l'inflation telle qu'on
l'a vu aujourd'hui elle frappe en
particulier les plus basses
rémunérations dans notre pays et c'est
le cas aussi pour les fonctionnaires de
notre pays donc c'est pour ça que moi
j'assume de faire porter des efforts
supplémentaires des efforts particuliers
pour celles et ceux qui dans la fonction
publique sont les moins bien rémunérés
c'est pour ça qu'on a concentré nos
efforts sur les bas salaires c'est la
raison pour laquelle on versera au mois
d'octobre une prime de pouvoir d'achat
une prime Macron de la fonction publique
ce sera de 800 euros brut à 300 euros
bruts jusqu'au fonctionnaire qui gagne
3250 euros brut de rémunération c'est
important et traverser en une fois pour
les fonctionnaires d'État pour les
fonctionnaires de la fonction publique
hospitalière pour 90% d'entre moi
d'octobre et 10% d'entre eux au mois de
novembre en fonction des réparateurs
rediscuter salaire parce que là on parle
de prime mais moi j'ai d'abord pris des
décisions qui vont s'appliquer certaines
se sont appliquées dès le mois de
juillet certaines je vous le disent sur
la prime pouvoir d'achat au mois
d'octobre d'autres et l'effort
continuera puisque au mois de janvier
2024 sera à nouveau une augmentation de
la rémunération fixe des fonctionnaires
puisque nous donnerons des points
d'indice supplémentaires c'est à dire
qu'on augmentera la rémunération fixe
des fonctionnaires et ça ça sera
d'application janvier 20 4 mais tout ça
a été annoncé parfaitement lisible ce
que nous faisons aussi et c'est le
rendez-vous que j'ai avec les
organisations syndicales c'est de mettre
en place des conditions pour mieux
discuter pour mieux négocier les
augmentations de salaire les évolutions
de rémunération au fond mettre en place
une forme de négociation annuelle
obligatoire pour la fonction publique
c'est le rendez-vous que j'ai donné aux
organisations syndicales pas d'ambiguïté
c'est pas pour remettre en cause les
décisions qui ont été prises annoncées
et mises en pratique avant l'été mais
c'est pour fixer un cadre de discussion
et je crois que ça serait effectivement
utile pour toute la fonction
mois d'octobre et vous l'avez dit pour
les fonctionnaires d'État pour les
fonctionnaires dans l'hospitalière
est-ce que il y a pas une injustice que
les fonctions publiques territoriales
n'en bénéficie pas alors je crois pas
une des demandes de la fonction publique
territoriale des employeurs territoriaux
c'est de garder des marges de manoeuvre
et vous avez déjà commenté avec moi le
fait que quand on prend des décisions
sur l'augmentation du point d'indice par
exemple il y a pas le choix pour tous
les employeurs territoriaux et ça
s'applique d'autorité si je puis dire à
l'ensemble des employeurs donc ils nous
ont demandé de faire différemment que la
part qui s'applique de façon automatique
soit un peu moins et qui puisse avoir la
main est-ce que ça veut dire que les
employeurs territoriaux ne verseront pas
de prime la réponse et non on leur a
évidemment mais donner la possibilité de
le faire en fonction des situations
certains avaient déjà fait des efforts
indemnitaires plutôt nature des primes
donc dans leur collectivité par exemple
et donc on n'a pas voulu imposer une
décision d'en haut sera à chacune des
collectivités de mener cette politique
céréale avec un peu plus
de votre part un cadre qui est fixé il a
été fixé il est décrets ont été pris dès
cet été donc les employeurs territors
sont absolument libres de verser cette
prime mais ils le feront dans un esprit
de confiance et de responsabilité vous
savez moi l'ensemble des réformes
l'ensemble de ce que je souhaite porter
pour la fonction publique c'est aussi de
redonner des marges de manœuvre de un
moment donné au fond un espace de
responsabilité aux employeurs
territoriaux je pense que c'est comme ça
qu'on pourra avancer on va revenir sur
la fonction publique dans quelques
instants mais vous avez parlé de cette
rencontre entre Emmanuel Macron et les
chefs de partis politiques le chef de
l'État qui avait donné jusqu'à hier au
chef de partie politique pour lui
répondre
ericsiotti a fait une réponse on peut le
dire en forme d'ultimatum à Emmanuel
Macron il réclame des garanties sur
quatre points le pouvoir d'achat
l'insécurité l'immigration la liberté de
la planète de la presse est-ce que vous
avez d'autres choix que de répondre
favorablement républicains et de céder à
leurs injonctions vous savez d'abord je
pense qu'on va pas avancer que avec des
lignes rouges il faut que chacun puisse
effectivement trouver des voies pour
faire émerger des compromis c'est
exactement le sens de la démarche du
président de la République elle est très
sincère notre pays
vit a vécu avant l'été une crise très
profonde une fissure dans l'unité
nationale les émemes urbaines tu as
quelque chose qui va se retourner comme
ça ça a marqué notre pays et donc notre
responsabilité c'est de tendre la main
aux uns et aux autres de le faire en
franchise de façon très sincère et donc
pour pouvoir faire émerger
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez moi je
crois que c'est maintenant la
responsabilité du gouvernement du chef
de l'État de mener des propositions de
faire des propositions il y a me semble
est-ce que vous allez y répondre est-ce
que vous avez d'autres choix que d'y
répondre favorables bien entendu et les
sujets qui sont abordés l'ont été par le
chef de l'État d'abord l'immigration
notamment une thématique qui me semble
très importante et sur lequel on peut
trouver des voies de consensus qui est
celle de l'efficacité de notre action
locale comment faire il faut vous m'en
parliez à l'instant pour donner aux
acteurs de terrain plus de marge de
manœuvre pour
faire c'est l'objet aussi du Conseil
national de leur fondation dans sa
version territoriale de ce qui peut se
passer dans le champ de l'éducation ce
qui peut se passer ensemble la santé je
crois que ce champ là d'action c'est un
champ sur la déconcentration sur la
décentralisation où on peut trouver y
compris avec nos oppositions des voix de
consensus il a demandé président de la
République a demandé à la première
ministre de faire des propositions
précises sur cette thématique là je
pense qu'on pourra avancer y compris que
nos oppositions mais ça veut dire que
vous avancez sur vos thématiques par
celles directionées je vais en citer
quelques-unes des demandes d'eriki à la
baisse des taxes sur les carburants vous
avez déjà un peu répondu la suppression
des allocations aux parents d'élèves
défaillants le rétablissement des peines
plancher un plan d'urgence de
construction de place de prison des
plafonds migratoires votés par le
Parlement est-ce que vous pourriez le
suivre là-dessus sur tous ces sujets là
nous avançons et pas que dans les
discours nous sommes le gouvernement qui
construit des places de prison en
l'occurrence et c'est pas tout le temps
facile de trouver les emplacements y
compris quand ce sont des maires de
position qui parfois au niveau national
demande des constructions passent de
prison de pouvoir avancer sur ces sujets
là donc aucun de ces sujets
tabou nous allons faire des propositions
avancées ou continuer d'avancer
par exemple sur l'immigration juste nos
concitoyens nous demandent de trouver
des solutions nous demandent d'avancer
efficacement sans idéologie et donc bien
sûr nous continuerons à apprendre sur
les migration pour vous c'est oui
moi personnellement je crois que c'est
pas le sujet qui est le plus pertinent à
présenter en référendum il faut pouvoir
je le disais à l'instant avancer
efficacement sans idéologie mal placée
si je puis dire sur ces sujets là avec
pragmatisme je crois pas que ce soit le
sujet principal aux yeux de pertinent
et qui crée effectivement un clivage
important je crois que sous nos demandes
nos concitoyens c'est trouver des
solutions immédiates de l'efficacité
dans l'action publique que ce soit
d'ailleurs pour faire appliquer la loi
que ce soit parfois pour des thématiques
comme l'intégration de celles et ceux
qui viennent dans notre pays qui
travaillent donc je crois que c'est
plutôt par l'action nous avons commencé
à proposer un projet de loi il a été
adopté au Sénat en commission il va
falloir continuer à pouvoir avancer et
le président de la République n'a pas
fermé de porte il a raison
c'est maintenant dans les prochaines
semaines que nous pourrons faire des
propositions plus concrètes et faire
avancer excusez c'est pas le meilleur
sujet sur pour référendum c'est quoi
c'est la fin de vie le meilleur sujet ça
pourrait par exemple être un beau sujet
de consultation ce sont des thématiques
d'engagement qui sont liées aussi à ce
que notre pays avec eux mais il faut
qu'on puisse pouvoir poursuivre cette
discussion là c'est la profession que le
chef de l'État a fait aux différents
partis politiques il y a une ligne rouge
pour les républicains c'est la question
de la régularisation des travailleurs
dans les métiers en tension est-ce que
pour vous il est inconcevable que ce
sujet ne figure pas dans le texte final
j'ai une correction très forte c'est que
cette mesure elle serait bonne pour
notre pays elle partirait du réel au
fond de la situation telle qu'elle est
je suis frappé de voir à quel point elle
fait consensus d'ailleurs sur chez les
acteurs qui sont au plus près du terrain
le patronat et largement favorable à ce
type de mesure les employeurs qui voient
bien que la situation c'est
qu'aujourd'hui certains membres de
personnes sont dans pays travaillent
s'intègre et sont dans des situations
ne figure pas moi je compense pas qu'on
va commencer ce débat en mettant de côté
nos convictions notre conviction c'est
que cette mesure elle est bonne et donc
moi je souhaite qu'on puisse avancer et
pouvoir la porter qui était design
exactement vous le voyez c'est pas une
question de référendum c'est exactement
le chant de la discussion parlementaire
légitime que nous pourrons avoir mais
moi je crois que cette mesure elle est
utile et donc je souhaite qu'on puisse
continuer à la porter il y a une
initiative politique entre l'aile gauche
de la macronie et une partie des députés
de gauche de la nuque sur ce sujet pour
porter justement cette mesure est-ce que
cette tribune vous auriez pu la signer
si vous étiez parlementaire je suis pas
parlementaire en l'occurrence je suis
membre du gouvernement et je vous dis
sans ambiguïté que je suis favorable à
cette mesure je crois que c'est ça la
clarté du débat politique
c'est de trouver surtout des la science
politique pour voter moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'on puisse trouver un
équilibre qui permet de dégager une
majorité pour pouvoir voter ce texte là
je note encore une fois vous comprenez
les députés macronistes qui s'habillent
sur cette mesure il a été fait par
Gérald Darmanin puisque au Sénat en
commission le texte que nous avons
présenté qui contient cette mesure a été
adoptée c'est donc quand on met un peu
les lignes rouges de côté parfois
l'idéologie ce côté sur ces sujets là et
qu'on avance avec pragmatisme on peut
trouver des majorités donc c'est mon
souhait à gauche comme à droite qu'on
puisse sur ce texte important nécessaire
avancer et dégager des majorité François
bayrouillère disait qu'il n'était pas je
le site pour qu'on fasse de
l'immigration au sujet qui allume le feu
il dit que c'est un texte utile mais pas
essentiel vous êtes d'accord avec ça je
dirais que c'est un texte nécessaire
aujourd'hui il faut pas faire semblant
de se dire qu'il y a pas de sujet que
tout fonctionne très bien que notre
système d'intégration d'immigration que
notre capacité à faire appliquer la loi
fonctionne donc je crois que c'est un
texte qui est vraiment très largement
nécessaire et c'est la raison pour
lequel
c'est d'avancer de façon pragmatique
peut-être pas de passer tout un temps de
débat je me perds pas dans les détails
aujourd'hui avec vous sur les modalités
du référendum sur l'immigration mais
donc on voit bien qu'elle serait
extrêmement complexe et peut-être
qu'elle nous ferait perdre du temps sur
un sujet sur lequel il est nécessaire
d'avancer plutôt rapidement avec les
instruments de la Constitution ou 49-3
en étain mais c'est toujours la même
chose si on se dit par nature qu'on va
forcément utiliser le 49-3 ou qu'on va
forcément ne pas être c'est le 49-3 je
crois qu'on fait une erreur il faut
d'abord essayer de bâtir des majorités
et ensuite prendre nos responsabilités
49 pro c'est ça au fond c'est d'engager
ça reste gouvernement vous êtes sûr
qu'il y a qu'une seule ligne en matière
d'immigration il n'y a pas celle de
Gérald Darmanin et puis cette douche
construit par plusieurs ministres il y a
une dimension travail qui est très
importante Olivier du sceptre a pris une
part importante dans la préparation de
ce projet de loi il y a une ligne une
seule ligne qui est celle de
l'efficacité je pense que il faut pas se
disperser dans des considérations trop
idéologiques sur un sujet où c'est avant
tout du pragmatisme et d'efficacité que
nous demande nos concitoyens Fabrice une
question justement sur la fonction
publique on y revient oui parce que vous
êtes ministre de la Fonction Publique et
de la transformation de la fonction
publique pour commencer déjà sur
l'enseignement une enquête ce matin
indique que il manque encore un
enseignant au minimum dans un
établissement sur deux aujourd'hui en
France c'est le cas vous confirmez
manquant donc vous voyez bien que les
efforts payent à plus d'enseignants que
d'ailleurs les enseignants qui sont
recrutés de façon contractuelle était
déjà pour 90% d'entre eux faut souligner
ce chiffre des enseignants qui étaient
devant les classes l'année dernière donc
en j'entends parfois que ce sont des
enseignants sans aucune expérience sans
aucune préparation sans aucune formation
qu'on fait venir devant des classes faut
très très largement relativiser ce
chiffre ce sont des enseignants
expérimentés et nous avançons en
confiance avec eux en redonnant notre
activité au métier c'est le cœur moi de
mon combat pour la fonction publique de
façon plus large c'est vrai que c'était
particulièrement visible sur les
enseignants mais il y a pas de fatalité
moi je crois qu'on peut redonner de
l'attractivité au métier si on s'y
attelle de la bonne des manières c'est à
dire au fond de travailler sur les
enjeux de fiches de paie et de
travailler aussi sur le sens au travail
sur les conditions dans lesquelles nos
fonctionnaires nos agents publics
peuvent exercer un projet de loi de
modernisation de la fonction publique
qui sera présentée quand mon objectif
c'est de le travailler et de le
présenter d'ici la fin de l'année pour
qu'ensuite on puisse examiner et qu'il
soit mis au calendrier parlementaire
mais je veux le construire je veux le
construire on verra pour le calendrier
parlementaire mais je veux qu'en tout
cas il soit prêt à la discussion je veux
le construire comme je le fais depuis le
premier jour en discussion avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes avec
évidemment les organisations syndicales
les retrouveraient dès le mois de
septembre pour discuter de l'ensemble
des sujets qui sont devant nous on
parlait des salariaux évidemment
j'aborderai avec eux les thématiques de
transformation de réforme parce que je
crois qu'elles sont nécessaires je les
dis il faut à la fois travailler à mieux
protéger nos agents publics mieux les
rémunérer répondre aux questions de
pouvoir d'achat répondre aux questions
aussi de protection physique mais il
faut continuer à réformer notre fonction
publique pour davantage mettre en avant
récompensé les compétences le mérite
permettent davantage de mobilité dans la
fonction publique pour moi c'est le cœur
du projet que je suis en train de
travailler Marine Le Pen a fait sa
rentrée politique hier à la fustigé la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron elle parle
d'un effondrement généralisé du pays
d'une déliquescence des services publics
et la politique d'Emmanuel Macron
pourrait être un mélange de marketing et
de malhonnêteté que lui répondez vous
au fond pas grand chose parce que c'est
tout le temps la même rengaine elle fait
depuis des années la même rentrée
politique avec exactement la même
rengaine c'est à dire celle d'un
défaitisme pour notre pays qui est
absolument pour moi hallucinant on a
l'impression quand on écoute ses
responsables politiques que tout est par
terre que rien ne va que rien ne marche
parfois je me demande même s'ils aiment
notre pays le sport national pour eux
c'est de le critiquer c'est de pointer
les difficultés c'est leur seule fonds
de commerce donc j'étais pas très
surpris de voir une rentrée politique
sous exactement la même rengaine
toujours et toujours celle du côté
notamment sur les services publics
j'ai jamais dit ça jamais quand on
pointe des difficultés forcément on peut
aussi mettre le doigt sur des points qui
dysfonctionnent mais ça n'est pas notre
pays de croire que tout est noir que
rien ne fonctionne que nos services
publics sont abats partout nous nous ne
commentons pas les choses nous agissons
pour les améliorer pour rétablir ce qui
mérite de l'être pour remettre de
l'humain aussi sur les territoires c'est
nous qui ouvrons 2600 maisons France
services et nous qui revalorisons les
professeurs du pays
bien sûr vous allez poursuivions vous
avez ouvert 6 et vous allez présente la
République à indiquer qu'il souhaitait
encore amplifier ce mouvement là nous
réouvrons des services publics dans les
sous-préfectures j'irai dans quelques
semaines inauguré une maison franc
service à Lannion dans une
sous-préfecture vous voyez cet
investissement là au-delà des discours
de défaite c'est nous qui sommes en
train de le faire et je crois que c'est
que ça qu'attendre nos concitoyens elle
fait des européennes une élection de
mi-mandat est-ce que vous Renaissance
vous êtes prêts pour ces européennes oui
bien sûr c'est une élection qui est très
importante mais pardon pas pour en faire
un rendez-vous de mi-mandat ou d'en
faire un rendez-vous politique
politicien si je puis dire c'est parce
que c'est très important pour l'Europe
et que nous notre engagement pour pour
l'Europe et depuis le premier jour
infaillible et pas d'une façon
européenne pour pouvoir changer les
choses au niveau européen nous avons le
groupe le plus influent au niveau
européen donc si les Français veulent
continuer cette politique au niveau
européen mais en changeant l'Europe mais
bien ce rendez-vous sera très important
à nous le verrons partie politique et la
majorité présidentielle dira dans
quelques semaines qui sera notre tête de
liste mais vous souhaitez que ce soit
qui est plus important c'est le projet
aujourd'hui européen et donc nous
choisirons les personnalités il y a
beaucoup de personnalités je me
prononcerai pas avec vous ce matin il y
a beaucoup de personnalités qui d'abord
on l'Europe au coeur ont agi à tous les
niveaux pour l'Europe et donc notre
majorité ne manque pas de personnalités
qui sont capables de porter notre projet
européen merci
c'est notre invité ce matin merci
bonne rentrée